hey there and welcome to the motion
science video podcast and today I'm
going to talk to you about why online
learning is more than just
button-pushing
[Music]
hey there and welcome to the motion
science video podcast my name is Cameron
and today I'm talking to you about why
online learning is more than just
busting button-pushing if I can say that
right and something I feel like is very
important to talk to you about because I
see a lot of people doing it okay and
what does it mean when I say that it's
more than just button-pushing what I
find is that there are so many tutorials
out there that are just teaching you how
to push buttons to create the same thing
that what they're showing in the
tutorial okay
and I'm not dissing on anybody I'm not
saying that this creator or this this
artist is teaching you something wrong I
think there's it's great when they when
they teach you exactly
I find myself like I go through those
tutorials myself and it's because I go
through them because I want to learn a
creative process okay not because I want
to learn to recreate the exact same
piece that this artist just created and
that's the problem okay that's what I
see a lot of artists doing a lot of
motion designers specifically because
that's who I'm following that's what
they're doing okay I also get asked a
lot within my own trainings like why
can't you zoom in on on this effect in
these numbers you're typing in I can't
see I can't see exactly because I don't
allow my tutorials I don't actually zoom
in and out on on values because I don't
want you to enter the exact same values
right if you're listening to what I'm
saying in my trainings I'll say like
okay we're going to type in an
expression here or like Mike one of my
favorite expressions is the wiggle
expression this so if you've taken any
of my trainings you know that I love the
wiggle expression I use it on a lot of
different properties from positions and
scales and cameras and lights and
effects and you name it wiggle can be
applied to about anything which is why I
love it right but I'll say my trainings
like hey you know type in wiggle
parenthesis 2 comma 25 and
you know parentheses and maybe you'll
hear me say but maybe I'm not zoomed in
enough where you can't quite see it
depends on the resolution of your screen
I record everything in HD so some people
working at 4k and larger displays and
things can be a little bit less can be a
little bit more pixelated and they can't
see these values and they'll say like I
can't see the numbers like you got to
zoom in I don't want you to put in the
exact same numbers right I want you to
see the process I want you to listen to
what I'm saying and you can by listening
you can input the exact same values but
I want you to take what you learn and I
want you to create your own thing okay
now again I'm not here to diss on
anybody okay but I see it all the time
like I'm a big user of Instagram so
currently so if I'm on Instagram I'm
constant getting tagged from different
artists saying hey you know hey we
repost this that's what they want me to
do which I'm not i repost some things if
you're watching this the chances of me
re posting your work are pretty slim it
has to align with what I'm showing
through motion science don't tag me with
stuff that's straight up vector
illustrations
unless it's texturized or they've got
that motion science flare to it because
I'm not gonna repost it right I don't
I'm not a big believer in that kind of
stuff so I will get tagged all the time
with these lessons that I can tell right
off the bat like this is straight off of
a tutorial I've either seen this
tutorial on YouTube or somewhere else on
social media I've seen other artists
creating the exact same thing maybe it's
a slightly different color palette that
they're working with or slightly
different you know objects but I see it
all the time I see it every day
right so don't there's nothing wrong
with you recreating something that
you've learned and watching someone
teach you button pushing but that's not
gonna make you a better artist that's
just gonna make you you're just going to
create work that you're gonna put on
your reel and as a creative director
myself I'm going to immediately
recognize that and say this guy doesn't
have natural talent this guy is a
button-pusher so if this guy someone
tells him enter these values he can do
that but anybody can do that right and
now I know and again I'm not dissing
anybody I just want you to think
differently about how if you really want
to be a motion designer you need to it's
okay to recreate something but don't put
it on your reel don't put it out there
take what you've learned and make it
your own
right that's what I teach through motion
science and that's where the world needs
to go with training that's why I created
motion science because I saw all of
these tutorials is specifically on
YouTube at the time and they were all
the same in terms of okay now we're
going to input a value of 10 we're going
to move X 100 pixels we're gonna scale
up a hundred and 2.3 percent and then
you see people creating the same work
over and over again there's a lack of
creativity right and like I said I'm not
the only one who can recognize this if
you want to work for a creative director
if you want to work for a production
company they're gonna recognize this as
well maybe it won't get caught right at
the beginning but someone's gonna catch
on late sooner or later if you get
brought into a studio I worked with an
artist one time as it for just for a
little story here I worked with an
artist he got brought in on a project
with a team of me and several other guys
and gals and he got brought in because
he showed this piece that he had done
and I'm not gonna name any names but he
had done this piece and it was an
impressive piece but he got burned in
this job and we quickly realized within
a couple days this guy did not know what
he was doing he literally pushed some
buttons that someone had told him what
to do or had taken it from a tutorial
and he had created this piece that sold
was sold him off of his reel but when we
were asked like okay we know you can do
this stuff so do that kind of same
technique to this project he couldn't do
it because he didn't understand the
process the workflow the techniques
enough that he could think on his own
creatively to create something so we
need to be original with the
that we're putting out there especially
on social media okay we need to take
what we learn and apply it to our own
work and make our own you know projects
based on training lessons the biggest
thing I could tell you right now is to
learn the fundamentals of design if I
can say the word fundamentals learn the
fundamentals of design learn the
fundamentals of motion right and you can
do that you can learn design
fundamentals you can learn motion
fundamentals by button-pushing by
watching trainings on tutorials on
YouTube or other creators and learn why
these fundamentals work right if I could
push anything right now
I would push style craft on you because
in style craft you learn the
fundamentals of design right and then
what makes good design what makes good
powerful motion design work and why does
it work and I do again I teach a lot of
this kind of stuff and pro flows as well
I don't let's teach you how to push a
button I teach you how to think
creatively how to go about about a
process and figure it out on your own
because you want to create your own
magical pieces right we all want to so
again I love the socials right I find
inspiration in Instagram and Pinterest
specifically those two every day I scour
those looking for inspiration and I look
at tutorials and trainings from other
artists because I don't know everything
right not just know everything and we're
always trying to push ourselves so I
love to go and learn from other artists
and see what they're doing and I've done
it since the beginning when I was in a
project as a remote artist you don't
have a team of people around you so when
you get stuck you really get stuck and
you have to figure out a way to do that
so I love to watch trainings and figure
out okay what's the what's the process I
need to go through to create what it is
I want to create and then I learn that
process but then I apply it to my own
work in my own special unique way as a
motion designer so you know use sites
like Pinterest and Instagram if you're
not following motion science on
Pinterest its
Pinterest calm such motion science
Instagram is the same instinct
Instagram calm slash motion science or
just search my hashed or
my hat symbol at motion science on both
of them follow my accounts Pinterest I
put a lot of inspiration up there I
don't post a lot of tutorials from other
artists on there but I do post a lot of
gifs and motion pieces and design pieces
because they are inspiration to me as an
artist so definitely check those out if
you haven't um but I love to look the
best way I can say to to to build your
own work and not just but button pushes
to find the pieces that inspire you and
they if they're not trainings they're
not tutorials that's that's okay because
you can you can see these piece these
pieces that inspire you and they inspire
you for some reason I want you to
dissect those pieces okay I want you to
look at a piece and see how are they
doing that and why are they doing that
not just how but why are they doing that
and what about this piece works what
about this piece really draws me in and
grabs my attention and makes me say wow
that's amazing motion design and then
figure out how they did it right figure
it out just break it down even break
down one little scene one little
five-second piece or a ten-second piece
break it down and I do it every day
every week I break down scenes that
inspire me but I create my own work
based on it okay so and if I don't know
how something is done like when I was
first learning parallax I didn't
understand it I found a couple tutorials
on how to do it I didn't take the same
image that they were doing I didn't even
take the same type of camera moves but I
would take the very basic principles and
apply that to my own motion design so
there's my speak my speech to you on why
online learning is more than just button
pushing and I think that if you approach
online learning as more than just button
pushing and you apply principles and
workflows and techniques to your own
work you will exponentially scale as a
motion designer I invite you right now
to check out Pro flows plus that's my
monthly membership I'm teaching so many
techniques and workflows every single
month every month this
membership grows it's where I'm putting
all my emphasis for motion science it's
all going into proof flows plus you're
going to learn how to do the how and the
why and it's going to make you grow as a
motion designer and I would also invite
you depending on the time of year to
check out style craft that's going to
push you even further right style craft
it opens up twice a year so that's my
speech for you today as always thanks
for listening what I have to say until
next time I'm Cameron and this is motion
science
[Music]